OPENING FACE-OFF IS WON BY
SATURDAY.
BUT ANDERSEN HAS THE PU-- THEY
LOW.NE.
WATCH THIS ONE HERE.
LOSES THE PUCK BA
BECAUSE, CAROLINA WAS ABLE TO
BREAK THE PUCK OUT IN THE
DeANGELO  DISCS IT.
REBOUNDED. ANDTHESE TWO
TEAMS. CONSISTENCY.
>>
>> CENTERING ATTEMPT TO THE NET
AGAINST A RARE SLEEPING
McDONAGH.Y
THOUGHT IS SHOT PAUL
HE JUST KEEPS SKATING.
BACK TO THE POINT.
OF THE NIGHT.
STAMKOS MAY GET THE  IT THROUGH
SLOT.LP GAIN
POSSESSION.
DEFLECTED OUT FRONT IN UNCANNY
CONFERENCE FOUL AND STANLEY CUP
YOU CAN DO IT.
>> IF YOU ADVANCE THE
CONFERENCE TITLE IN THE STANPUR
BOUNCING PUCK.
FAST  FORRESTARTEDTHE POINT.
NOW PUT ON.
FAST HAS THE OPPORTUNITY.BACK T
BACK STANLEY CUP CHAMPION FOR A
REASON!
WITH THE PATIENTS TO CONTROL IT
AND SLIPPED IT PAST
OF THE BLUE LINE NOT TO TURN IT
OVER.
HE TIPPED IT OVER SO JARVIS
COULD GO TO
HE WALKS IT IN, AND IN AN
ELITE MANN
STAMKOS WITH A QUICK SHOT.HANDL
HE WAS BOXED OUT NICELY BY IN.
GETS HELP.
BUT HIS PASSES  DETECTED.
HE HAS BEEN ALL OVER THE ICEHIT
LOCK.
KEEPING THE PLAY ALIVE.
HE HAS ANDERS
OUT FRONT!DEFINITELY